[Music]
if you're working with large amounts of
data from multiple sources unifying your
data leaks and data warehouses is
important but knowing what products to
use and how to architect the right
solution for your data analysis needs
can feel overwhelming when starting from
scratch if you're looking for a way to
store process analyze and activate data
using a unified data stack we've created
a jump start solution to show you how to
set up an analytics Lakehouse secure an
analytics Lakehouse using a common
governance layer build dashboards from
the data to perform data analysis and
create a machine learning model to
predict data values over time instead of
building your own solution from scratch
our jumpstart solution allows you to
quickly explore and easily deploy a
working solution to explore on your own
and help you determine what tools and
solution flow works best for your needs
if if you'd like to make your own
changes and customize it further we've
also built the foundation of the
solutions in terraform which you can
pull locally and modify as much as you'd
like and while these Solutions aren't
built to be production ready they do
include examples patterns and the Google
Cloud tools we recommend you consider
when building your own analytics
Lakehouse Solutions the example
Lakehouse architecture that this
solution deploys analyzes an e-commerce
data set to understand a Retailer's
performance over time let's quickly
review the architecture of the Google
Cloud resources that this solution
deploys the architecture represents a
common data flow to populate and
transform data in an analytics Lakehouse
architecture first images and tabular
data lands in cloud storage buckets then
a data lake is created in datax data in
the buckets are organized into entities
or tables in the data Lake datax will
automatically discover metadata data
from your structured and unstructured
data stored in
GCS tables are then generated and
immediately available in big query as
Big Lake
tables you can run data Transformations
using spark serverless or big query and
using open file formats including Apache
Iceberg data can be secured using policy
tags and row access
policies machine learning can be applied
on the tables
and lastly dashboards are created from
the data to perform more analytics by
using looker
Studio to try out this jump start
solution yourself simply click deploy
and our solution will guide you through
these steps and automatically create and
configure all the resources needed to
run this solution this solution can be
deployed from the console or by using
terraform once deployed you're free to
explore how the solution is built and
help to determine what tools and
architecture from this jump start
solution can be used for your own data
warehouse needs want more information
resources and troubleshooting tips check
out the solution guide this is your best
resource for any questions you have on
this jump start
solution remember this solution is for
demonstration purposes only and is not
intended to be used in a production
environment however feel free to play
around and customize it before creating
your own custom Arch texures based on
our provided framework in this jump
start tutorial ready to try it out
yourself check out the links in the
description to deploy this jump start
solution and see additional learning
resources to dive deeper on this topic
we'll see you in the
[Music]
cloud